das ist super die situation einer front
sprechen ich bin seit knapp zwei wochen
zurück ein offizier dort sagte mir dann
war es das was zu uns geliefert wird ist
zum gewinn des krieges zu wenig und zum
sterben zu viel
warum entscheidet sich die regierung
nicht klar
die deutsche regierung aber auch andere
dass die ukraine gewinnen müssen und das
habe ich ja schon klar und deutlich
formuliert dass die menschen in der
ukraine ein recht darauf haben in
frieden und freiheit und sicherheit zu
leben und dass frieden und freiheit nur
zu gewährleisten ist wenn die
landesteile wenn man uns das anschauen
da wo jetzt russische truppen stehen
dass die ukrainisch wieder sind auch die
krim ist gewinnen für sie also wenn sie
sagen die ukraine musste krieg gewinnen
bedeutet dass mit der krim mit dem
gesamten ost die die krim ist
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert deswegen
gibt es seit 2014 sanktionen aufgrund
dieser völkerrechtswidrige besetzung der
krim welche schritte wann wie wo gehen
das ist aber das ist die definition der
gewinn für sie wenn sie sagen können
musste krieg gewinnen werden wenn die
ukrainische regierung souverän über ihr
staatsgebiet entscheiden kann und was
dann da vivo dazu gehört das nicht ganz
allein in den händen der ukrainisch
demokratisch gewählten regierung und
nicht in den händen irgend einer
ausländischen regierung und deswegen
sagen wir klar so undeutlich wir
unterstützen die ukraine dass die
menschen dort in frieden aber auch in
freiheit leben können all diejenigen
jetzt auch sagen ja gut aber wenn keine
bomben fallen dann ist das aus meiner
sicht nicht automatisch frieden und
freiheit die abwesenheit von krieg
bedeutet eben nicht dass man automatisch
frei leben kann dann muss man nur einmal
aber was bedeuten ihre worte zu gelangen
janowski ja fragen aber was soll das da
fallen keine bomben und trotzdem ist
gelangt nicht frei und und das ist so
wichtig wenn wir jetzt darüber reden
warum wir auch in der situation
militärisch die ukraine weiter
unterstützen selbst in der zeit
offensichtlich die die russen
militärisch stärker auftreten sie halten
starke reden und sie sind da in der
diskussion auch ganz klar und auch mit
antworten aber wenn wir uns die
situation so anschauen ist es das seit
wochen keine deutschen waffen mehr
dorthin gelangt sind
warum zwingt sie den kanzler nicht dazu
mehr waffen zu liefern oder warum sagen
sie nicht gut wenn das nicht passiert
werden wir eine neue regierung sagte
den letzten halbsatz auch wenn er
überspitzt formuliert war wie ich
vielleicht auch gerade überspitzt
formuliert habe in der derzeitigen
situation wenn es industriell stärkste
land in europa sagt wir haben neuwahlen
ich glaube größeren gefallen könnte man
dem russischen präsidenten überhaupt
nicht mehr druck das unerwartet darauf
einmal das einmal gesprochen keine
waffen wir angekommen sind da stimmt er
nicht also mit frage seit wochen die
panzerhaubitzen ich wollte die wir
geliefert haben und ein weiterer liefern
die sind in den letzten wochen
angekommen wir haben jetzt noch mal
erhöht wir haben mit blick auf die
weiteren lieferungen gerade auch mit
blick auf flugabwehr auch mit blick auf
drohnen in den letzten wochen immer
wieder material geliefert arbeit von
mein großes aber das ist nicht perfekt
das ist vollkommen klar wenn die ukraine
militärisch überlegen wäre dann hätten
wir andere situation es ist aber eben
auch nicht so einfach wie man sich das
vorstellt wir haben seit jahrzehnten die
bestände der bundeswehr massiv
reduzieren wir haben jetzt mit dem
panzerhaubitzen erstmalig aus beständen
der bundeswehr geliefert ich hatte schon
in der vergangenheit gesagt ich finde
wir müssen uns anschauen was ihren
beständen möglich ist und zugleich haben
wir verpflichtung innerhalb der nato ich
kann jetzt nichts sagen wir geben alles
aber wir haben einfach nicht mehr so ist
das habe ich nicht gesagt ich habe
gesagt wir schauen uns ganz genau was
können wir abgeben machen sie nicht mehr
druck vor dem hintergrund warten sie vor
dem hintergrund dass wir zugleich
zurecht dem baltikum versprochen haben
wenn ihr angegriffen werden dann wären
wir da das heißt all das müssen wir in
balance bringen plus mit berücksichtigen
dass wir sehr viele teile haben das habe
ich in den letzten monaten sondern alle
lernen müssen sie haben zwar in den
beständen dann faktisch irgendwelche
zahlen an panzer oder an zahlen von von
auch artillerie
funktionsfähig ist aber nur ein teil
davon so wie reflektieren in der
bundesregierung gemeinsam bewegen mehr
tun können auch mit blick auf den
ringtausch wo wir sehen das ist
offensichtlich nicht so funktioniert wie
das geplant war zu schauen damit dann
auch wirklich das material anfang was
ist da los
also wir hören zitat aus dem spiegel der
polnische vize außenminister zitat die
deutschen versprechen zum panzer
ringtausch haben sich als
täuschungsmanöver ergebnissen ist eine
art vorbild
und in so einer situation enttäuscht man
seinen europäischen nachbarn ich habe
die gespräche ja auch geführt das macht
jetzt die zuständige
verteidigungsministerin weiter von
anfang an war klar dass wir natürlich
nicht von heute auf morgen mit dem
finger schnippt jeden einzelnen panzer
ersetzen können keine neuen panzer die
haben ja selber gar nicht sondern die
müssen ja überhaupt dort seien aber
offensichtlich ist gerade mit blick auf
polen die situation so dass wir nicht zu
einer lösung kommen die für alle
unbefriedigend ist also das macht mir
auch spaß ist jetzt auch hier das
falsche wort ja dass das
geheimnis liege natürlich allen an die
nieren die hatte mein sage ich unter
anderem auch wenn wir uns jetzt darüber
streiten dass sie einen sagen zu viel
was so wenig was können wir liefern
warum wir nicht erst mal die ihr habt
auch das ist ja eine frage die man sich
stellen muss also natürlich können sie
sagen wir wollen mehr von euch haben
aber trotzdem können die panzer die sie
haben auch direkt in die ukraine gehen
ich möchte noch einmal verstehen weil
sie ja wirklich mit ihren worten sowohl
im bundestag in interviews immer sehr
klar sind sie sagen wir müssen ihn
unterstützen im training muss gewinnen
und gleichzeitig passieren diese dinge
das verstehe ich nicht die polen sind
sauer auf deutschland die ukraine sind
immer noch sauer alle sagen das kommt
nicht genug haben sie persönlich genug
dafür getan aus ihrer sicht den kannst
du davon zu überzeugen dass mehr
geliefert sind
mit absolut ist man habe ich eh nicht so
habe ich würde man aufhören sich ständig
zu verbessern deswegen jeden tag schauen
wir dass wir besser werden können und
auch besser werden können in der
unterschiedliche versteht total ihren
punkt und nichtsdestotrotz ist es so
dass wir auch mit blick auf ihre auf die
nachbarländer immer schauen müssen was
können wir leisten wir sind ihr könnt
ihr euer leisten
das ist natürlich auf kosten anderer
bestehen gerade gesagt werden sie dafür
mehr schwere waffen in die ukraine zu
bringen jetzt in den nächsten wochen ich
habe mehrfach deutlich gemacht dass wir
aber der hat ja larry schauen müssen wie
wir das verstärkt unterstützen können
eine letzte frage damit ich sie da
verstehe warum liefern wir denn nicht
eigentlich leo zwei marder fuchs panzer
warum sagen wir nicht wir tun jetzt
alles damit sind sie ja sagen die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt warum tun
wir nicht mehr an mir liegt das liegt
das an olaf scholz und warum handeln so
liegt das daran dass wir tatsächlich
angst haben vor allem atomschlag dass
wir angst haben vom platz putin mehr
oder weniger direkt
angegriffen werden können
also bei den konkreten fragen sich jetzt
gestellt hat da liegt es nicht daran
natürlich müssen wir immer reflektieren
was bedeutet unser handeln deswegen
haben wir zum beispiel zu beginn des
krieges als gefordert wurden ist
flugverbotszone einzurichten wo der
erste reflex ja auch sein könnte das
muss man auf jeden fall tun als man
damals die bombardierung gesehen hat wie
viele menschen ums leben gekommen sind
haben dann entschieden dass wir das
nicht tun können weil wir dann
militärisch in diesen krieg hätten
eingreifen das ganze selber mit
flugzeugen in die ukraine hätten fliegen
müssen deswegen haben wir uns an dem
punkt für einen anderen schritt
entschieden und das gleiche gilt jetzt
ich mache einen großen sprung weil wir
immer vor der eigenen verantwortung wir
diese entscheidung treffen auch für die
menschen in unserem land in unserem
gemeinsamen europa haben mit blick auf
die panzerlieferungen deutlich gemacht
und auch mit blick auf den ringtausch wo
ich in
brüssel beim nato-treffen ganz stark
dafür geworben hatte weil es in der
situation so schien dass es am
schnellsten geht wenn wir alte
sowjetische panzer liefern können wir
sofort bedient werden können wenn sich
herausstellt dass das nicht funktioniert
aber wie gesagt das liegt nicht allein
an uns weil die panzer könnten ja sofort
geliefert werden dann müssen wir uns
jetzt gemeinsam anschauen und das tun
wir in der bundesregierung warum das
offensichtlich nicht passiert und ob wir
dann andere unterstützung leisten müssen
aber diese ringtausch frage die haben
wir ja auf den weg gebracht weil es uns
zu dem zeitpunkt das beste und
schnellste mittel schieben denn dieser
weg nicht richtig war und ich weiß nicht
wer in kriegssituationen immer sofort
weiß das ist der perfekt richtige weg
dann müssen wir das natürlich
reflektieren und schauen wie wir dann
arbeite ich aktiv werden